virtuelle währung auf dem prüfstand was
hat es mit bitcoins und ähnlichen
digitalen währung auf sich und wie kommt
man überhaupt daran jetzt bei klicks um
science fiction die zeiten in denen man
zur bank geht und geld abhebt oder
vielleicht sogar mal ein zahlt könnten
bald vorbei sein virtuelle währung wie
bitcoins leid coin oder rippe sind mit
ihrem blog chaim system im anmarsch
wir nehmen heute mal diese virtuellen
währung unter die lupe schritt für
schritt angefangen hat das mit den
bitcoins und dem rest anfang 2009 ein
jahr nachdem sie zum ersten mal in einem
whitepaper von satori nakamoto
vorgestellt worden waren wurden die
ersten 50 bitcoins in die welt gesetzt
was war der grund dafür zitat das
kernproblem konventioneller währung ist
das ausmaß an vertrauen das nötig ist
damit sie funktionieren der zentralbank
muss vertraut werden dass sie die
währung nicht entwertet doch die
geschichte des fiat geldes ist voll von
verrat an diesem vertrauen banken muss
vertraut werden dass sie unser geld
aufbewahren und es elektronisch
transferieren
doch sie verleihen es in wellen von
kreditblasen mit einem kleinen bruchteil
an deckung wir müssen den banken unsere
privatsphäre an vertrauen vertrauen dass
die identitäts dieben nicht die
möglichkeit geben unsere konten
leerzuräumen so satt roshi nakamoto als
fiat geld wird übrigens ein tauschmittel
bezeichnet das keinen wirklichen wert
hat also ein geldschein zum beispiel
beim tauschen von waren mit diesem fiat
geld müssen wir also darauf vertrauen
dass der wert so stimmt die virtuellen
währung sind also so konzipiert dass wir
selbst alles in der hand haben schauen
wir uns doch mal das so genannte blog
system dahinter an ein blog ist
sozusagen ein virtueller und
anonymisierter kontoauszug einen
kontoauszug wie der den man wie gewohnt
am bankautomaten bekommt zeigt man
wahrscheinlich nicht jedem oder ein blog
ist dagegen für jede person mit der man
geschäfte macht einsehbar auf das
jetzige system übertragen würde das
heißen man nagelt seine kontoauszüge
einfach anonym
auf ein schwarzes brett und jeder kann
sich durch lesen wie der geldtransfer so
aussieht missstände wie zum beispiel
fragwürdige transaktionen oder ähnliches
damit direkt auf alle teilnehmer in
diesem knoten netzwerk stimmen
einheitlich über transaktionen ab was
das system sicher machen soll mit einer
elektronischen währung die auf einen
kryptographischen beweis beruht und kein
vertrauen in mittelsmänner benötigt ist
geld sicher und kann mühelos
transferiert werden das sagte sat uschi
nakamoto über das system was dakar motor
allerdings nicht erwähnt
bei der ganzen selbstbestimmung findet
eine wichtige kontrolle nämlich die
staatliche nicht mehr statt jeder kann
etwas überspitzt gesagt tun was er oder
sie will und muss dann zwar nicht auf
mittelsmänner aber umso mehr auf seine
partner vertrauen der
vertrauensmissbrauch ist also keineswegs
ausgeschlossen
plötzliche ereignisse bestätigen dass
rund 120000 bitcoins wurden der bitkom
börse bitfenix womöglich sogar von
firmeneigenen mitarbeitern gestohlen
der wert dieser bitcoins beträgt fast 60
millionen euro wird eine bitkom börse
bestohlen oder ist fehlerhaft durch
hacking oder software fehler kann es zu
kompletten system ausfällen kommen an
geld kommt man dann erstmal nicht mehr
ran für eine freie verfügbarkeit ist
einem solchen fall definitiv nicht
gesorgt es wäre denkbar dass durch
virtuelle währung die etablierten banken
ihren einfluss verlieren allerdings
haben banken im gegenzug eine rechtsform
sind also im zweifelsfall sogar belang
war falls etwas schief läuft
einige große banken arbeiten derzeit an
einem rahmen system in dem virtuelle
währungen benutzt werden können jetzt
aber mal zur ausgangsfrage wie kommt man
überhaupt an bitcoins und dergleichen
vergleichen kann man die beschaffung von
bitcoins ein bisschen mit in game käufe
für rund 500 euro je nachdem wie der
wechselkurs gerade steht bekommt man ein
bitcoin dieses bitcoin hat man dann in
seinem portemonnaie samt digitale
portemonnaie dieser extrem hohe
wechselkurs bringt direkt ein weiteres
problem zum vorschein der einstiegs
betrag ist immer sehr hoch es geht immer
um riesige summen ein system mit dem man
anonymisiert und schnell große mengen
geld transferieren kann bringt auch
große gefahren mit sich im darknet
können kriminelle handlungen erleichtert
durchgeführt werden dort ist es möglich
mit bitcoins zu bezahlen in den letzten
wochen war das aufgrund des anschlags in
münchen häufig im gespräch da wurde ja
eine waffe im darknet gekauft anonymität
bezug auf währung kann uns also noch
teuer zu stehen kommen es gibt also
einige vorteile die für virtuelle
währung sprechen allerdings fehlen
einige regulative mechanismen auf jeden
fall sind bitcoins und andere virtuelle
währungen schon ein teil des
finanzsystems wir können gespannt sein
wie sich unser verhältnis zu geld und
virtuellem geld in den nächsten jahren
entwickeln wird spannendes thema genau
übrigens wie dass die lüge der
energiewende das waren sich hier in dem
video einfach draufklicken wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat lass mir gerne
einen daumen nach oben da oder ein
kostenloses abo dafür hier klicken
ja und nicht interessiert jetzt eure
meinung zu diesem komplexen thema was
meint ihr was haltet ihr vom virtuellen
währung schreibt mir in die kommentare
und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran